hello and welcome to this video playing
chromis okay Tomas doesn't want to play
five it seems it is a funny funny Lyonya
doesn't play play the capture it should
be five what do I do
95 is 98 funny reply okay then 92
probably playing on the lights for the
light squares you can even consider 94
in desperation like immediately
attacking
okay
we are going to attack this the center
White has a good development that sets
debts for sure but it looks very
weakened just six yeah I don't think I
need to get that Bishop out or anything
the bishop is not in danger of becoming
a bad piece I can always like to take on
d4 and and open open things up that's
interesting
and that's a good move probably
okay
a transform locator one to five I don't
like this so much I should plate that
differently
yes I should have played dance
differently
a bishop before I just wish it before
[ __ ] and everything would be nice I
wanna add even bluntness house
I should kind of frankly just take it
put it very stupid very stupid claim now
I'm not a not completely unhappy here
but if you just get gifted an exchange
you should probably take it the move I
didn't even consider didn't even
consider it
but it's of quiet possible I mean it's
possible the stupid keemei can just end
it by grabbing the exchange and it's
very very very pretty stupid stuff I
mean I'm not winning
after getting the exchange but yeah
he came so I seems very confident with
this points that I'm probably correctly
so what a damn stupid game now I can
push the apron a-five a-six and so on
it's probably relatively easily winning
Kings on the way to c6
since he doesn't mind that I take this
hi a nice nice little trick here of
course I cannot take because of b5 takes
would be one but then I have cooking a
five separately except so bad check
check check
yeah yeah but ok let's not let's not the
end of the world at all I can take here
[Music]
I have to approach I mean quite clearly
time were they don't understand anything
absolutely I don't understand anything
why don't I just win the poor now I
would see a dot then he just stays hmm
now it's hard for me to do anything
[Music]
let's think about it thinking is
difficulty with this time situation and
I came
check what did I give him this porn it
was extremely stupid yeah yeah whatever
have taken h4 and now I'm playing this
far too quickly
check check check check
I want a stupid move kind of yeah
want to give the check I am making more
stupid mostly I crazy
it is really crazy check check check
check
although I didn't have an all time I
have weird room I was just win this
friggin game
I got what what a nonsensical look
ending and a half minute sometimes I'm
just do to panicking I would with a
little time on the clock that's just a
completely easy win descending and it
should have never happened of course but
the way you played and all the
completely winning ending okay so a bit
of a weirdo opening here yeah this is a
funny funny idea this gets the calm back
get the default bond back
okay so this yeah and he took and played
the cell and maybe this was a what's to
slow why anything possible I don't know
I don't think this is a big issue but I
don't like the position or that much
yeah of course I was Bishop before I am
here
I simply simply didn't put didn't take
this into account
auntie this is just a bad ending the
team yeah never did something with the
queenside pause so step-by-step he was
wandering it away yeah and then this
good yeah I mean this is just c6 is
completely completely wrong let's take
f7 and try to draw and yeah I should
just win I mean that that's really bad
Oh gauge 5 home just pick stuff off pick
up stuff and that that should also be
enough but I really played some
extremely stupid moves I mean I just
blundered the h1 here and now it's a
draw yeah okay don't make much sense to
analyze anyway over 20 seconds nobody is
going to play well William okay guys
thanks for watching